do you have any clue what's going on in
death straining no me neither to help
clear up this fact Hideo Kojima has
revealed a little more information on
his mysterious upcoming game I'm
tomorrow and this is a confused gamespot
news update seeking at sony playstation
spree Tokyo Game Show keynote
presentation kajima revealed the meaning
behind the game's title and logo
according to him the games logo isn't
dripping ink or liquid the trails we see
beneath the letters are in fact cords he
went on to explain that the theme of the
game is about how people are connected
by strands hence the title of the game
death stranding he revealed that the
game will be in the action genre and
that it will be open world with a degree
of freedom the game will also have
online elements and Kazuma spoke of his
wish to give gamers a way to be
connected via these strands or elements
that are different to the usual
multiplayer teams in addition he
confirmed that death stranding will be
available in 4k resolution and support
HD our destiny was first announced at e3
this year by a surprise appearance from
Kojima himself beyond a rather unique
trailer we don't really know much else
about the game other than it will be
released for playstation 4 and PC Fujima
has said the game will be the best he's
ever made and he's confident that he
won't have to make any compromises are
you excited for their stranding or just
confused let us know in the comments or
come and find me on Twitter I'm at two
more hedge and for more on Kojima and
death drowning make sure to keep it
gamespot